and even with more coveted restrictions  across nevada and the whole country  there are some good signs today on the  jobs front we have the newest  unemployment numbers out from the labor  department  712 000 more americans filed for jobless  claims last week which is better than  expected  keep in mind the government will release  the monthly jobs report that is tomorrow  and we will bring that tomorrow  it is expected though the national  unemployment rate will be 6.8 percent  and that is a slight decrease  here in nevada 7 400 more people filed  for unemployment that is also lower than  expected  and lower than the week prior so at  least moving in the right direction  if you are looking for work right now we  have a great resource online to help you  find local companies hiring  just go to eightnewsnow.com click on the  community tab  then the job board tab